that gentleman down there it's in
exactly the same was what you said he
said someone obviously had a big night
yes I nail sorry we're just plugging in
their line yeah I'm very good thank you
[Music]
yes yes it has turned but will it go
forward is the big question
it has gone down the water level
no no he's pulled it further off that
leading edge I'll talk to you about
looks more equal
yes
I'm killing Daisy
sorry babies come around a little bit
tough step
you go back a little bit
I need I'll do ya
[Music]
it's actually much better angle for us
because you can see the tugs a bit more
180 degress really it's gone through
1990 from sight
it is but in the last few minutes there
has been quite a lot of movement the the
ship when we got down here and and from
the early hours of this morning was
totally Sidon flat to this Beach about
thirty meters away from the shore the
shoreline but since they've had high
tide you can see these four tugs in
front of the ship have been pulling the
boats engine has been running and it
looks like these what you're seeing now
is the ship being successfully pulled
out from the shoreline you may have just
heard a ripple of applause from the
people who've gathered to see what has
been a quite remarkable rescue effort by
the emergency services here and I think
yet we can confirm that this boat is out
of it it looks like it is it is now
moving forward quite freely which will
be a great relief to the Coast Guard's
here because they had a very very narrow
window of opportunity only about 45
minutes of high tide in which to try and
turn the boat out towards the sea and
pull it off which it has now
successfully done that of course very
very good news but a few things I will
now need to look at is whether there has
been any damage to the reef which was
one of the issues that the ship had in
getting out there was it was a wedge
between a bit of the sandy beach and and
some rocky reef which lies just
alongside this coast here in Falmouth
whether there's been any damage to that
whether there has been any pollution
leaks of course this is a cargo ship and
although there wasn't any cargo on board
there would have been some fuel and the
Coast Guard says it's pretty optimistic
that none has leaked into this Shore but
now really the question is how this ship
managed to drift so close into the shore
before any alarm was really raised as we
understand from looking at some map äj--
of its tracks that it dropped anchor at
about three o'clock this morning because
of these extraordinarily high winds and
high seas that were battering the
southern coast but what happened then
after it dropped anchor was that it was
able to then drift really closer and
closer and closer into Shore
that the alarm was raised not until
about 5:45 this morning but the good
news down here in Falmouth that this
ship has been able to get safely away
from shore now a great relief to the
Coast Guard who I said if they have
missed this opportunity they wouldn't
have had another go until high tide this
evening and with bad wind and further
rains forecast that was not something
that anyone here wanted really to
undertake
okay can we just do a quick piece to
camera with it go up and ask them where
do you envisage you couldn't you
couldn't have you couldn't have paid for
that could we do maybe so sorry then an
end service and I emerge in the frames
and worth you I don't know how we can
yeah
yep and what a welcome sight this is the
ship safely sailing back out into the
English Channel
that way we go
and what a welcome sight this is the
ship safely sailing back into the
English Channel and into deeper waters
the question now for the coast guards
and the people that own the ship is how
did it get so close and so far oh of
course in the first place
can I just do one more please thank you
and what a welcome sight this is the
ship safely on its way back into deeper
waters and back into the English Channel
for the coastguard water relief they had
a very narrow window of opportunity here
whilst high tide was still in effect if
it hadn't done it now it would have had
to wait until it was much darker it was
going so well and what a welcome sight
this is the ship now safely on its way
back into deeper waters and into the
English Channel for the coastguard it is
a massive relief they had one shot at it
during this high tide if they didn't
rescue this ship now they would have had
to wait until later on this evening
right pricey head